again terribly sorry for what happened  before this is small what I had in mind  now to whom am i speaking  the son who returned scatter his  mother's ashes or the lunatic who has  murdered his way to the top of my  Mountain  you see what pagan has done to this  country like it or not your cuties  curate and your choices will carry  weight we need someone to break the  stalemate between a metre and Sabang  stand with us and I promise you you will  fulfill your mother's dying wish  this is about lives we don't like people  who die  the right choice was obvious  I'm trying to take us out of your  third-world [ __ ]  hey Phillip Kira who do you cheer for  I came in a sane man came out like this  you you are come out a team do what you  came here to do  ah  pre-order now for a free upgrade to the  limited edition includes three extra  story missions and a bonus Impaler  harpoon gun pre-order now far cry 4  available November 18th 2014